I met with a web designer and I showed
him this piece of paper that I drew out
and study hall and he's like let's make
it happen
people aren't just gonna you can't just
sit back and everyone's gonna listen to
you or you're gonna sit back and
everyone's gonna get work you gotta like
really grind and do whatever it takes
and make those connections and push
every boundary you ran this up the right
way properly
you want need motivation watch a top 10
would believe nation what's up at 7 my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see exploded
on to the world so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack on showing
today's lessons from the founder of a
music promotion and event coordination
company lyrical lemonade he's Cole
Bennett and here's my take on his top
ten roses success joy
alright let's kick things off with rule
number one make it happen
my name is Cole Bennett I own a company
called lyrical lemonade it's still
difficult to kind of explain it as a
profession you know I mean because
naturally people just don't take it
seriously but I would say I'm a music
promotion company event coordination so
in production I throw shows I do music
videos we do merchandise I'd usually
just summarize it like that I met with
the web designer and I showed him this
piece of paper that I drew out and study
hall and he's like let's make it happen
and I'm a real stoked and I got a 200
stickers made I went to high school just
past mile tall my friends and we did
have them on their agendas and stuff and
you know I tell a lot of people about it
some people thought was really cool all
my friends were supportive and then some
people were like what are you doing
right yeah I mean he's stupid
he knew what he wanted to be you know he
didn't want just fake videos i he knew
he wanted to create an empire he wanted
to create something so special I know
every like that's what you did exactly
that rule number two is take every
opportunity seriously when we shot the
Speed Racer video which is one of my
favorite videos by the way that video
was like the start of everything for
Warhol cuz that's such a good look for
him and it's like you really kind of
just everybody watches that video who's
sort of involved in the industry would
probably be thinking like damn who did
that video exactly so that video opened
up a lot of the lanes for me like when I
was editing that Warhol was at a point
where I was like you know do some people
gonna see this can be cool but it's not
gonna benefit me any great amount I just
want to help him so when we put it out
and were like I remember he said he was
like a hundred thousand views and I was
like in my head I was like there's no
way and now I was that like four hundred
fifty thousand views and like that's
unbelievable because I never thought it
would be at that point but that helped
me so many ways not even as it would
like I was just trying to help him and
then when it came out is like you know
like Keefe's manager called me like I
was on the phone with chi-chi's manager
for like 45 minutes
no and that was incredible for me
because they're like they're watching my
Instagram whatever and they were like
watching my videos they said and they're
like about to contact me and then they
saw one day when I put the snippet up
for the Warhol video there's this shot
where I put up a Keefe poster uh-huh in
like well there's one of the scenes so
like there's they saw the piece and
there's I call they call me a Chiari
gang and you know from there we're just
talking like clogging and everything and
and yeah like we watched everything and
that I got the opportunity to meet Keefe
a few months later and you know I showed
him you know some of the videos and he's
like I already know who you are and like
that was the craziest thing ever and
that stemmed from Speed Racer you know I
mean so you never know what you know you
don't know what your hips are gonna be
basically you could be working with
anyone you know whatever you never know
where that products can go so that's why
I think you should take everything
seriously because something that you
thought was gonna be something you know
small and no real local could could blow
up in a certain extent to a certain
extent yeah rule number three
build your brand do you ever watch other
people
the vision videographers like video
YouTube channel and see what they up to
you are doing to be honest but I mean
sometimes I definitely feel that I look
up to soon no use there were this
inspiration if you could heal these
videographers I'd listen tips could you
get
I would too
brand yourself open
videos out there
I feel like it works time right now
where I said producer videographers
artists obviously all have the shot at
at building their own their own as much
as the people performing music can feel
like if you grant is up the right way
properly
you can do anything you want but if he
could learn about that if you don't
really attach your name to it or
normally build your own trademark thing
no one's ever okay rule number four is
start small it's like you hear I feel
when I started like doing everything and
it's like he like passing out stickers
that my friends made have it on their
agendas we've messed around might be
record songs on grojband and it sounded
awful
I mean we're just messing around really
now with these music videos on my mom's
camera and like we've got videos here
and we shot videos all over the town and
you know the high school really liked it
it was just fun for the time being and
then I realized like I actually really
liked beauty videos so I started
branching off and doing some work city
with like real small local guys and then
that send in you realize
that I wanted to see more involved with
the theme I was like why don't I start a
blog and then you know be able to
further knowledge myself on the theme
and stuff in different waters and do the
thing so I thought I don't want to do
that rule number five do it for free
anyone trying to get into anything when
I tell people like you're gonna work for
free for a little bit you know maybe for
a while like you worked for free in that
you might were getting pay for the first
you probably took some losses on some
shows you yeah I've definitely taken
lots of time shows and you know I've had
incredible shows he's just like there's
always ups and downs like my first music
videos I remember when I first started
working with Chicago artists um and
there's one time where I was like sent
this kid like this what do you link that
I wanted I was like as soon as it the
package is to my house was like a twenty
dollar hoodie as soon as the package
gets to my house or at least a video
like I was just like you know whatever
worked like I was doing like fifty
dollar videos twenty dollar hoodie
videos whatever it was um you know it's
just like you got start from from
nothing to just work your way up and
just find that at the beginning a lot of
people are too prideful to understand
like sometimes y'all do free videos
sometimes you gotta you know you know
you know just do whatever you can to
make it work and you know once you do
that once you establish yourself you're
able to to charge however much for a
video you're able to do this and you
know you're on a list here whatever you
know but you got to push those
boundaries beginning because you know
that's the only way you're gonna be hurt
it's like people are just gonna you
can't just sit back and everyone's gonna
listen to you or you're gonna sit back
and everyone's gonna see you at work you
gotta like really grind and do whatever
it takes and make those connections and
push every boundary and push every line
and do whatever you can to to make those
people here because they're not just
gonna hear you rule number six work
super hard
my junior the summer leading into my
senior year my senior year football I
was really busy I mean obviously we had
like two days we had doubles we had
practice every single day so like
literally after practice you know if
there's something going on in the city
we'd go like small music garage shows
whatever it was like I remember like
Alex Wyllie we'd have shows like Lincoln
Hall like
regi shows whatever it was there's
something the city or like if someone's
willing to pay me like 20 bucks for a
video I was going that's like you know I
just drive out to the city and we'd make
it work and I come back that night and
wake up OPA
rule number seven always do your best
when you're putting out so much content
and trying to be creative at the same
time like you run into this problem of
too many moving parts sometimes but I
don't like what I did was every piece
that I would work on I want to make this
the best possible thing I can make and
whatever it kind of comes with it comes
and I'm gonna go until I can really make
that change and I can really build a
platform for artists and I can make
something new rule number eight just be
yourself
what advice would you give to someone
out there like wants to be the next Cole
Bennett well I mean it depends it's
really whatever you want do but I think
that just like a lot of people right now
I feel like with the scene and where
it's at and everything everyone's trying
to be something they're not
like everyone wants to dress a certain
way because everyone's doing that
everyone wants to do this or that and
it's just like I think just knowing what
you want and going about in the right
way in just being yourself is the best
way as corny as that sounds like I don't
worry you know supreme or whatever that
because everyone else is doing that like
I just the Birkenstock pretty sure trash
the framing socks but on avenge that I
do you know maybe brought some supreme
but it's just like if I like it like
it's just like I'll never I think it's
really about just you know just being
yourself rule number nine my personal
favorite take responsibility a lot of
challenges come with growing a show
obviously you have a headline artist who
people are going to see but if anything
goes wrong it's lyric lemonade you know
I mean it's not whoever that headline
artist is so you have you kind of have
to understand that whatever you're
creating no matter how many people are
involved it goes back to one person and
rule number ten the last one before the
bonuses give people opportunities
YouTube channel has almost turned into a
platform so I can give people
opportunities and I can really break new
artists and that's so fun to me okay
I can hand pick someone who I really
believe in do a video for them and you
know if if enough people be with me as
far as you know talent or if they enjoy
the artist then BAM you know that that
might be a chance to break them and
possibly change their life
now I've got some special Cole Bennett
bonus clips for you but before that the
question of the day is what do you think
about doing work for free good idea bad
idea have you done it do you regret it
are you doing more of it let me know
leave it down in the comments below
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love see you soon and
enjoy the bonus clips
there's this guy named Austin Baisley
who directs all Chancellor rappers and
if you're from Chicago like chance the
rapper like he means so much because
what he did for Chicago and just like
watching his growth was incredible so
his his videographer Austin Pez Lee that
was like my whole inspiration so when I
was you know shooting videos and you
know coming up with these you know you
know storyboards and everything for the
videos I was just like try to make it as
cool and as Extreme as possible and we
didn't have many resources but um you
know we just we just did what we could
and I think that you know trying to just
like make your own lane and just like oh
no just being as creative possible with
it and and and just doing whatever you
want with it not they just say focus
don't get involved with the wrong people
or the wrong crowd and
I don't really really just thank you to
yourself and there's a brand of the
company and keep working at it whatever
it's like palpable and do a lot of
research I don't make all the necessary
and proper stuff raise your standard
Apple at the core its core value is that
that people need passion and change the
way people not one drop of myself work
depends on your acceptance of me
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten roses success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link the description for details